president salivate
Bharti Majumdar
and smale ladies and gentlemen welcome
to the first of this year's Tanner
lectures thank you all for coming I want
to give you an overview of events to
begin with immediately after today's
lecture you're all invited to a
reception which would be straight out
the doors to the back of the auditorium
and down the hall in room 108 the second
lecture then will take place tomorrow
afternoon again at five o'clock right
here after it there will be time after
the second lecture there will be time
for questions from the audience on
Friday morning at 10:30 finally we will
regather with Professor Chakrabarti here
again for further discussion of his
lecture as a discussion that will
include Daniel Lord Smail from Harvard
University and Yale zone yg Dimmick and
Michael Warner the Tanner lectures on
human values were established by the
American scholar and industrialist Obert
Clark
Tanner born in 1904 Tanner studied at
the University of Utah and after
receiving a law degree there he pursued
philosophy at both Harvard University
and Stanford University at Stanford he
became acting chaplain and was later
appointed to the faculty in religion in
1946 he joined the Faculty of philosophy
at the University of Utah from which he
retired in 1974 he published several
books on the New Testament Oh Burt
Tanner died in 1993 meanwhile back in
1927 in his mother's basement Tanner had
begun an industrial enterprise that grew
to be the largest firm of its kind in
the United States the OC Tanner company
jewelers specializing in corporate
recognition awards provided the material
base for the extensive philanthropies at
Tanner and his wife Grace in creating
the lectureships
Tanner hoped that they would contribute
to the intellectual and moral life of
humankind
he saw the purpose of the lectures as
the advancement of and reflection on
scholarly and scientific learning
relating to human values appointment as
a Tanner lecturer he expected would be a
recognition of uncommon achievement and
outstanding abilities in this broadly
bounded arena given these hopes and
expectations there could scarcely be a
more worthy Tanner lecturer than Dipesh
Chakrabarti from the you know
Chicago professor Chakrabarti is the
Lawrence a Kimpton Distinguished Service
professor of history and South Asian
languages and civilizations
he holds subsidiary appointments are you
ready for this also in English
comparative literature the Center for
Contemporary Theory cinema and Media
Studies and the Law School the mind
boggles at the very amount of committee
work that he must have to do in all
these places have I left out anybody
when before moving to Chicago professor
Chakravarthi taught at the University of
Melbourne and the Australian National
University from which he took his PhD in
1984 to say that professor chakrabarti
as a historian is to speak the truth his
latest book forthcoming this year
concerns the Bengali historian Jagannath
Sarkar and is entitled the calling of
history and professor Chakrabarti has
often shared in his writings glowing
intuitions into the thinking and doing
of histories
last year in fact he was awarded the
Toynbee prize for his contributions to
global history but his influence has
opened out to far wider horizons than
those of most historians he is a
foremost theorist of post-colonial t
global modernity and transnational
capitalism in these endeavors he took
his start early as he was a founding
member in the 1980s of the subaltern
Studies Committee or Sultan Studies
collective I'm sorry the mix of critical
theory and historical craft has served
him brilliantly well his widely read and
hugely influential book provincial izing
Europe is theorized history and historic
eyes theory of the most bracing sort
professor chakra Mardis post-colonial
project is a distinctive and nuanced one
provincial eyes in Europe was as the his
title suggests in part and exercise in
describing the local habitations of
European structures of thought and
colonial practices but it's theoretical
stance was not an assertion of
unfettered cultural difference of the
sort sometimes encountered in the 1990s
his intent as he noted some years later
was not to militate against all
Universalist thinking in the humanities
not too provincial eyes all things and
thus PluralEyes human reason itself as
no more than
the shifting product of local
constraints and contingencies instead he
aimed at understanding human universals
as necessary but unstable placeholders
in negotiating the translations involved
in gesturing out from local habitations
to understand and I quote him how font
is related to place was his effort how
Universalist notions are always pinned
down to local histories and life ways
the importance of such local habitations
in his thinking they are signaled again
in the title of his collection of essays
habitations of modernity has never
receded this has determined for him a
nuanced position distant from scholars
of sheer difference as I've said but
also firmly resistant to those whose
confidence in stable usually Eurocentric
truths remains unshaken even today along
another axis it has placed him at odds
with certain other conceptions of
modernity advanced by post-colonial
theorists of a different strike than he
he has opposed gently always in his
polemics those who aim to dissolve the
impact of local local life ways into a
uniform transnational non place
inhabited by all of us in the era of
globalized capital this path in his view
cannot avoid a facing crucial difference
distinctions introduced by locality
itself and cannot avoid as it effaces
them reasserting the very relations of
power it had hoped to escape once again
professor John Kirwan Chakravarthi
insists the relation of thought to place
needs to come to the fore in emphasizing
it he carefully maps a path between the
global vectors of capitalism in the
modern age and their local contingencies
since about 2008 professor Chakraborty's
thought has taken a new dramatic turn
one evinced in several important essays
one that we will hear about today and
tomorrow this is the turn toward
thinking the Anthropocene thinking that
is the period when human interactions
with the environment grew from the play
of affordance and exploitation common to
all living species into something new
and different the period when for the
first time on earth a single species
interaction with the environment or
effects as large and pervasive as
geological shifts themselves
in an essay of 2009 that became
overnight standard reading in this arena
professor Chakrabarti enunciated some
general implications of humanistic
thinking about climate change he saw
approaching the collapse of distinctions
constructed by the end of the 19th
century between human and natural
histories he began to describe the
interlocking of two distinct
chronologies the interlocking of these
chronologies those of the human
institutions at capital as an industrial
ISM and globalization and those of
geology and evolutionary and evolution
sorry and those are those of geological
and evolutionary timescales he began in
his own words to conjoin our deep and
our recorded history x' and at the same
time he began to describe a new mode of
post humanistic thought as it appeared
through the post-colonial lens a species
thinking very different from that
described in the long german century of
hegelian and marxist thought this new
direction does not come without huge
challenges for our thought and one hopes
our actions here in no doubt simplified
form is one basic challenge a professor
a question professor Chakrabarti raises
before us and will explore today if I
thought must needs be localized shaped
by the contingencies of habitations and
life ways how do we adjust it to move
forward against a global catastrophe
that looms ever more clearly how in
short does thought marshal itself to
action when its local habitation is
planet Earth please join me in welcoming
professor de peche Chakravarthi
you know as you get hold of this not
just ordered certain historic moments
there are funny kind of trade-offs you
make with technology so when and this
will interest Gary when I recorded the
technology of recording music came to
India many of the old musicians who
actually transited to recorded music
found this problem that they were used
to even when singing yelling where is
the microphone required them to modulate
their voice and to express emotions and
they said you either have emotions so
you have my voice you either have my
either have my eyes or I don't thank you
very much Thank You president salami and
and your tenor committee Gary Tomlinson
for inviting me to give these lectures I
realize what a great honor and privilege
it is to have been so invited since
we're having questions at the end of is
the trade of I can't see your faces now
I can see why my own words better but
you can hear them better there'll be
questions at the end of the second
lecture fortunately it so happens in the
first lecture is it longer so I'll
probably fill up a better part of the
what could have been a question time but
we're trying not to fill up all of it
so as you heard from some time now I've
been thinking about the question of
climate change not obviously as a
scientist or a policy person or even as
an activist I've been very interested in
thinking how themes to do with
globalization which is what I'd been
studying before even though from a
post-colonial angle interact with
the science of global warming and and
this becomes particularly visible in the
discussion to do with climate justice
and that's what I will come to it it
mainly as the IPCC scientist limit
scientists began to say that this
particular episode of climate change was
anthropogenic or human induced questions
arose naturally as to who would pay for
the damages it caused and on the
polluter pays principle it was decided
first at the Rio conference of 1992 and
then at the Kyoto Protocol of 1997 that
the principle for paying for the damages
that climate change causes would be that
would be the assumption that nations and
people bore common but differentiated
responsibilities now the expression
differentiated responsibility and this
is a lot of time at politics turns
around this particularly between nations
even when they gather in Paris the next
time this will be a critical question
the idea of differentiated
responsibilities is quite easy to
understand and I understand that the
meaning is that it's the Western
developed nations including Japan who
had done most of the emitting of
greenhouse gases of the offending gases
and therefore they should be and so in a
way that I the expression common but
differentiated responsibilities it's
clear that is the it's these two words
coming together differentiated
responsibilities that bring the story
that the scientists tell which is
actually about relationship between
climate and what they call alert
processes
into a relationship with the familiar
stories of globalization there is
interrelationship with the uneven and
iniquitous history of world capitalism
the emergence of a global media and a
global market and so on so it situates
the idea of differentiated
responsibility actually situates climate
change as a climactic point in the
history of globalization but the
question I'm going to ask in these
lectures in the two lectures is how do
we understand the word commonly in what
sense is responsibility common as well
was common simply an empty rhetorical
bargaining device used to placate the
Richard hundred insistence on the
responsibility of emerging powers like
China and India was it a word that was
meant simply to defer the responsibility
of the emerging powers the idea that
they would become responsible to but
only after they had industrialized
enough and had committed and they
emitted enough greenhouse gases to
qualify but then there was also this
recognition and this has only grown with
every report of the IPCC that the
problem of global warming produces its
own timeline for urgent global action
irrespective of the question of
responsibility mainly because that most
fear doesn't think about who is more
responsible that is if we were to avert
the truly dangerous effects of climate
change which unfortunately and unfairly
would affect the poor more than the rich
so scholars are agreed that planetary
climate change cannot be addressed as a
problem as distinct from many from the
many actions we can take regionally or
locally so the planetary aspect of
climate change cannot be addressed
unless there's a global political will
that will help humans deal with their
shared planetary crisis a lot of
scholars have actually made this point
that what is needed is that we have all
our economic transformations
happen quickly enough so that the world
can come together so that even the
Indian the Chinese governments are happy
that never enough economic development
so that we can come together in time
with a global political will to address
this problem now for a host of reasons
the global response has been much slower
than needed and global warming does not
even merit the same level of public
discussion in nations such as India
where corruption and environmental
pollution a supreme concerns so in an
interesting way
even though these are two big themes of
our time global warming and global
globalization global warming itself is
somehow not as global as an issue as
globalization is now I do not intend to
explain why global response to climate
change has not been as forthcoming as
many think it should have been there are
many interesting explanations we can go
into those explanations when we discuss
you know them from wicked problem thesis
to human perceptual problems with
anything that develops exponentially I
as I said my aim is much more modest so
basically I want to share some thoughts
with you on the word common in the
expression common but differentiated
responsibilities I submit to you that
the word common is much less obvious
than the expression differentiated
responsibility its meaning is not given
both the word common and what it may
stand for when we say common
responsibility may actually have to be
composed in the dot Orion sense of the
word so even if it was thrown in as an
empty word during the bargaining it
actually takes a certain significance
bra from being empty and therefore opens
up an area for both intellectual and
then political work for actually the
composition of what might be referred to
by the word common and there Fred my
basic rob corddry fundamental
propositions I start from is that the
story
globalization and the idea of
differentiated responsibility are
important necessary but insufficient
part of what needs to be explained now
it's true that this common cannot be
composed that is our planetary
collectivity cannot be composed ever by
ignoring the intensely politicized and
necessarily fragmented domain of the
global that understandably convert
scientists statements about humans as
the cause of climate change into a
charged discussion about moral
responsibility and capability but we
cannot think the commonly by immersing
ourselves in the politics of climate
justice either view such politics will
always reduce climate change to a
problem of globalization and its
discontents that is to the familiar
themes of power and injustice what the
climate score our Clive Hamilton said
recently in response to an essay by
Ulrich Beck is pertinent here and
Hamilton said one cannot come to grips
with climate change if it is cast only
as a problem of power relations and
differences between humans and that's my
starting point so my starting point in
these lectures is the observation that
for all their overlaps the stories of
globalization and the stories the
climate scientists still with regard to
global warming have this one difference
separating them humans are central to
all stories of globalization celebratory
or critical the science so that is one
could say that stories of globalization
are necessarily homo centric in the way
they're told the science of globalized
global warming on the other hand invites
us to see humans on an expanded canvas
of history spanning the geological
history of the planet and the story of
life on it by life I mean natural
reproductive life not by us to follow
Agamben and our
and reworking of Aristotle and to
bracket for the moment the disagreement
that Aristotle scholars have expressed
with our Gambon's errant inspired
reading of the Zoe bias opposition life
not humans emerges as one of the main
concerns of the literature and climate
science I will describe these points of
view respectively as homo centric and
zoe centric views of the world I'll
spend the time my disposal today in
setting up a framework for situating and
handling this distinction tomorrow I
will elaborate further on the
implications of this distinction for
thinking the word common in relationship
to the expression differentiated
responsibility so from where and how
does the humanist historian begin to
think in order to contribute to the work
of composing the common without in the
process denying all that divides us in
the space of politics while others may
propose different starting points let me
begin by retrieving an idea that was
mooted in the period when the fear of a
nuclear winter was a widely shared field
where people were thinking kind of out
of a horizon of catastrophe and the
particular I have idea have in mind is
signaled in the title of today's
tonight's talk is the German philosopher
Karl Jasper's conception of what he
called an epochal consciousness yes
press is not an arbitrary choice since I
was trying to think overall about the
human condition in the Anthropocene I
was you know the German standout for
making the entirety of humanity for a
long time the object of historical
thinking so it's not accidental that I
go to a German scholar but two aspects
of his category epochal consciousness
have some relevance to what I'm trying
to do here
yes pers a is as yes press thinking on
epochal consciousness comes out of a
particular tradition mainly German as I
said of taking the or taking all of
humanity as the object of philosophy of
history
and be relevant also is the point that
Jasper's the invented this category to
find the form of thinking that did not
foreclose the space of the political so
was Cold War for his time space of the
political and yet created a space of
thinking but he got is a perspectival an
ethical space that he imagined as pre
political now pre political not in the
old Hobsbawm sense in a particular sense
so pre political in the sense that he
thought epochal consciousness was a form
of consciousness that that's not deny
decry or denounce the divisions of
political life while seeking to position
itself as something that comes before
politics as it were so pre a pre
position as it were in a pre position
with regard to the political in other
words the question behind this thought
experiment was this is it possible to
develop a shared perspectival position
that can inform but not determine
competitive and conflicted actions by
humans when faced with the unequal and
uneven perils of dangerous climate
change when we know that climate change
will affect the poor more than the rich
while we also know that the rich have
had more to do with the emission of
greenhouse gases than the poor so given
this unfairness of the outcome of
climate change can we create a position
which doesn't deny the politics that
could come out of this unfairness out of
a sense of justice but at the same time
that is not completely immersed in the
political so this I think this was a
form of thought that yes press was
working on for quite a while even before
the Second World War and in the book man
in the modern age that was published in
German in 1931 and in English in 1933
yes first spelt out the idea of epochal
consciousness as a problem that haunted
the European intellectuals for more than
a century furthermore he argued that it
was a problem that had become urgent
since the Great War from which time the
gravity of the peril to humanity had
become manifest to everyone so in a way
I'm trying to go back to this European
tradition I'll try to identify
things in it it's features that we can't
accept anymore today but still try to
retrieve from it a way of thinking that
I think is healthy in the present
context so he explained epochal
consciousness as follows he said man not
only exists but knows that he exists in
full awareness he studies his world and
changes it to suit his purposes he has
learned how to interfere with natural
possession causes a causation epochal
consciousness for gaspers was then a
particularly modern phenomenon a
phenomenon that was possible only after
man had learned to interfere with
natural causation but one has to keep in
mind that is a form of consciousness
it's an ideational entity a product of
thought or as Jasper's put it man is
mind and the situation of man as man is
a mental situation so let us follow you
Spurs a little further while there had
been transcendental and universal
conceptions of history before Christian
Judaic Islamic passed on from one
generation to another the continuity of
this chain argue Jasper's was severed in
the night 16th century with the
deliberate secularization of human life
this was the beginning of the process of
European domination of the globe it was
an age of discovery he says the world
became known in all its season lands the
new astronomy was born modern science
began the great era of technique was
dawning the state administration was
being nationalized so the French
Revolution for him was the first TV
event that found expression in the forms
of epochal consciousness in the work of
philosophers and he discusses that but I
but he actually goes on to mention Kant
Hegel Kierkegaard Goethe Tocqueville
Stendhal neighbor
Italian Marx and others and among others
Nietzsche as bearers of different forms
of epochal consciousness ending his
series with Walther Rathenau Azul kritik
der zeit 1912 and Spengler's decline of
the West 1918 as two books displaying
forms of epochal consciousness that
preceded his own book man in the modern
age of 1930s and we can of course add to
this list other names of the 20th
century including
those
Martin Heidegger inherent an epochal
consciousness in each case was thus tied
to this question of humans perceived
capacity to project themselves into the
world as a collective sovereign entity
so HIPPA call consciousness was both a
form of thought and a genre writing for
the form could find his fully formed
expression only in writings that sought
to grapple with this consciousness and
therefore yes his own book the atom bomb
and the future of man the future of man
becomes as a question very visible from
the 1930s Andre Malraux actually wrote a
novel called man's fate in the early
1930s so this question what is the
future that humanity faces which was a
kind of late 18th century question comes
back in a big way in the 20th century
and in the book on the atom moment
particularly after the bomb in the 50s
the book on in this book yes / sought to
capture an age through a critical
discussion of some of the historical
statements some of certain historical
statement that summed up for him the
dominant motives of the time his opening
sentence saying this is something we can
actually mimic in relationship to our
times so this is what he said about the
bomb and if you replace the bomb by the
global warming you can see what his was
trying to grasp and altogether novel
situation has been created by the atom
bomb either all mankind will physically
perish or there will be a change in the
moral political condition of man this
book is an attempt to clarify having set
up this opposition he said this book is
a attempt to clarify what strikes us as
a choice between two fantasies that
either man will perish or the moral
political condition will change what
will happen is obviously something in
between you but he makes it clear that
he needed these fantasies to work
towards a new moral political condition
of man and I will register some
differences with Esper's in the course
of both of these lectures but let us
stay stable with him a little further a
game before going on our separate way
yes Percy explains why dating while
dealing with difficult consciousness
called for a new mode of thinking that
stood at a distance from academically
specialized disciplinary formulations
and he called these specialized thinking
calls
departmental thinking and basically
makes the point that departmental
thinking is not very and he includes
politics as specialized thinking and he
says that faced with extremity
specialized thinking is not very useful
and in an interesting way to reminded me
of a statement by Harvard the Harvard
economist Martin Weitzman which I've
used in some of my writing where he
recently said with respect to climate
change that the problem that economists
have in converting climate into risk
propositions about risk and their
favored policy is that the policy
Sciences work better if the risks are on
the lower side but if the risks are
catastrophic
then it's very hard to formulate policy
so in some ways his argument was that
specialized thinking is badly placed in
dealing with problems of what he was
looking at was a nuclear winter problems
of that scale and the other argument
that actually had been developing his
conversation with friends is that one
day it might be possible to look at the
social science disciplines politics
economics history and other disciplines
anthropology to examine whether or not
all these disciplines have actually
assumed what we might one day call
Holocene assumptions but you know that's
a topic for the future so moving forward
he explained that this non department or
non specialized thinking is best
understood he said from the point of
view of a general listener or reader who
listens to experts and specialists
explaining their view of a global
problem somewhat similar to our
situation to me physicists biologists
military men politicians theologians who
all individually declare himself
incompetent out at the outside a special
field while the listener or reader is
supposed to understand them all to check
their statements understandingly as best
as he can to gain an overall insight and
to judge them in his turn on an overall
basis now but where is this complete man
where is this general man who is
listening to all the specialists and
coming to their own conclusion and it's
clear reading yes pers that this figure
is not an empirical figure because even
in his own time he was quite aware that
not everybody was interested in
discussing the nuclear threat so it's
something that he's create
so he's actually creating a position
where both he himself as the reader and
he himself as the writer he sees these
two figures as the figure of the general
person who is actually contemplating a
disaster and finding departmental
thinking not useful not not helpful so
therefore his so he's actually hoping
that and yes press is struggling to
produce a form of thought that issued
from and address the position of an
imagined general reader or listener
joining a Spurs in thinking at the limit
of departmental thinking and on the
existence of issues I'm quoting that
concerned the whole and are up to
everyone so so the risk you taking of
course turning to this German mode of
thinking is that they're thinking the
whole all of humanity and here of course
there's presence again very interesting
because he actually goes on to say but
the whole is always fragmented it's very
hard to actually get at the whole but
I'll come to that that later having set
up the whole but other important
characteristic in the meanwhile of Hippo
called thought as yes pres conceived of
it was a negative one and this I find
very interesting and useful it was
negative in the tape in the sense that
he said the typical thought was granted
to men without giving him the rest of a
conclusion therefore it takes stamina
I'm coaching and calls for endurance in
the tension of insolubility
for what it brings to bear on philosophy
is not I'm quoting a matter of academic
that is departmental training but a
reality in man as a truly human as truly
human as a rational being so again this
is something with which I will take
issue but but but somewhere he is saying
that that the reason why I think of
empirical conscience is coming before
politics is is this idea that human
beings have to confront as it were the
danger they're faced with and have the
resource of rationality according to him
as the means with which to deal with it
and come to a sense of resolve
within themselves for dealing with it
and then enter the political so he's
kind of creating this perspectival
position which in his own imagination
gives the general reader and the and and
the listener or the hearer the the
resolve that is needed because he goes
on to say that a purely political
thinking which is not informed by this
result is not helpfully that a loss in
extremities because it's an extremity
that political thinking he says needs
the resolve of the human being in houma
change is sought wrought by extremity so
extremity has to work on the human being
facing it and that's the human being who
is not thinking out of specialist
thinking mmm and this rationality is
something that yes was believed in
thought that if you didn't believe in
the rational core of the human being he
was lost your faith in man is something
I'll come back to with I disagree with
it but but that's the point he makes and
he was as I said very well aware that
while we can in the gesture of a deity
construct for ourselves an image of the
whole is like this is what the gods see
an astronaut said once looking at that
the opinion that we can know what the
whole is historically or at this actual
moment really is fallacious however one
chooses to regard the epoch it remains
one of a number of obtainable
perspectives of orientation so in the
end then epochal consciousness itself is
this is a methodological endeavour in it
to get out of specialized thinking to
think about the whole but while granting
that you actually can't get a whole
which is beyond your own perspective so
there's no objective whole and therefore
to for he that suppose acknowledges it
that actually to create an epochal
consciousness as a perspectival point
from where to look back on a crisis is
it self up the certain kind of
precarious in the experiment that it is
in the danger of falling back into
partisanship so maybe it is in the
danger of becoming of looking political
and therefore that's where the
intellectual struggle is to create that
space and therefore it remains the
thought experiment a thought experiment
in the face of enemy
agency that requires us to move towards
composing the common some of the epochal
things that have marked the writings of
many european theorists going back to
south Gaspar's colleagues from cold war
to the fall of the wall in 1989 may be
listed as follows the end of the
Europeanisation of Turk the question of
constructing a multi civilizational post
European world that otherwise ran the
risk of technology promoting a culture
of uniformity the emergence of the
planet or the glue as the whole earth or
the other hula as a space for human
dwelling as such these themes that we
encounter sometimes the globalization
literature actually came up in gaspers
generation and have carried over as I
said into globalization discussion but
with the difference we have to remember
that much of the literature and
globalization in post-colonial theory
was directed against a particular fear
that accompanied this world historical
consciousness of European intellectuals
thinking in the German tradition
thinkers such as Heidegger gaspers
gadamer Schmitt were all concerned about
the possibility that once Europe lost
control of the world it had brought
together under its imperial ages only
technology would her world would hold
the world together producing a dull
uniformity in world cultures that could
leave humans feeling homeless this was
one reason why they were all interested
actually in dating the period from which
Europe declined so in a way they all
these European thinkers very interested
in provincial eyes in Europe in their
own way gadamer for instance from whose
proves I once borrowed the expression
provincial eyes in Europe wrote in
nineteen forty seventy seven that Europe
got provincial eyes his word as early as
1940 nothing but the sciences he said he
walked any resonance anywhere yes purse
gives a date later I mean he also says
today the century of expansion is over
and the European rule is over in his
Nomis of the earth Carl Schmitt dated
the decline of geopolitical Eurocentrism
from even earlier than 1914 for him it
began
the Monroe Doctrine with the rise of
American power really and the uniform
figure ii fear that these european think
has had and i'm just make these points
to distance myself somewhat from this
tradition from which i'm borrowing ii
fear and post-colonial literature and
globalization which there was a response
to that particularly cultural aspects of
globalization literature was the fear of
the uniform figure of the masked man
that haunted them again Jasper's wrote
about it that films i mean they looked
on films as producing this uniformity
take technology was producing this
uniformity and we human beings meet each
other less and less on the ground of our
respective faiths Heidegger made the
same point very famously or infamously
in an interview to - we go
in 1966 technology tears men lose from
the earth and uproots them and gadamer
writing an essay 1983 expressed the same
fear and the same fear that you can you
can find in writing all of these people
including schmidt that somehow this
unity of the world that is made by
technology and that's why they saw that
among as the culmination of that history
of technology which will render man
homeless and out of that came certain
questions of culture like gadamer was
arguing that every culture must be
authentic in itself in order for human
beings to actually use the planet as
their globe and meet together and
post-colonial literature and and
globalization literature I think was
very much in a conversation with this
tradition while opposing the fear that
technology would necessarily produce
this mass man the uniform mass man and
this is what you find again in schmitz
the story that myth tells in the normals
of the earth of the earth so it kind of
Sweeney in a 2008 essay published in the
American historical review the historian
Benjamin lazier described the this kind
of historical thinking which also has
affected historiography particularly in
the second part of the 20th century
marked as marked by a veritable lexical
spill from world histories to
history's and then from global to
histories of planetary concerns now he
started in the writing books Harrison
Bashford has written a book on the
history of the population problem when
the people begin to get together to
think about population as a planetary
problem or Joyce Chaplin's book on
Europeans going around the glue creating
a sense of the planet and therefore of
this you can what--when him in la series
talking about the spill from world to
global to planet and of course the words
like world and globe and planet are not
stable entities world history once
looked like the global history until in
the 90s when the very phenomenon of
globalization prompted historians to ask
if world history needed to attune its
itself to a distinctly global age as
Michael Geier and Charles Wright put the
question in 1995 or indeed as Bruce
Mosely sashed in 1991 if indeed the word
global could ever be fully subsumed in
the world world a similar instability
has I could argue has attended the fate
of the word planetary as it has traveled
from the literature and globalization
where analysts used the word globe and
planet as one and the same to the
literature and climate change so if you
look I'm just reading a couple of
sentences from Smith's the Nomos here's
one sentence which says the compound
term globe at live global linear
thinking he says it's better than
planetary or a similar designation which
refer to the whole earth but failed to
capture his characteristic type of
division or the first attempts in
international law to divide the earth as
a whole according to the new global
concept of geography began after 1492
these were also the first adaptation to
the new planetary image of the world so
what I'm saying is that while we have
had these words come up for a long time
in a lot of this literature you'll find
the word globe and the word planet being
used as synonyms it can be seen from
these quotations above that for the
theoretical approach meat was attempting
to develop to understand the production
of the global in human history planetary
was simply another word for global it
referred to the planet we live on the
earth taken as a whole this is exactly
how many of the latest scholars of
globalized
to reduce the word planetary to refer to
the earth as a whole and this was of
course a fulfillment of what many from
Heidegger to slaughter jig had seen as
the age of the world picture of the
global age and from the point of view
from this point of view the famous 1968
NASA picture of the Earth taken from the
space portraying the planet as a sphere
that rises over the horizon of the moon
the one entitled earth rise in many
places actually the this is what the
picture looked like so it's not really
authorized it's it's not the moon is
flat and you see Earth come up but in
many reproductions they turn it by 90
degrees to make it look like Earth rise
may be seen as the culmination of these
of the use of the picture of the earth
as a globe the planet on which will
happen to live it is humans looking in
and picturing the whole earth this is
Lucas from 1972 it's humans looking at
and picturing the whole earth as their
home the planet is what the globe is
other planets are not in our field of
view so one of the themes I'll develop
later on is that climate change comes
from a science which actually one part
of it was actually engaged in what I
call interplanetary studies so there
were those scientists were never simply
thinking of this earth as either our
home of the only planet so they had all
other planets in view but this is a
picture in which only the earth is in
view these pictures symbolized for
observers theme of human dwelling its
fulfillment as well as its breakdown
Heidegger expressed this crisis well in
his 66 interview where he said as he saw
the first pictures he said I don't know
if you were frightened but I at any rate
was frightened when I saw pictures
coming from the moon to the earth we
don't need any atom bomb the uprooting
of man has already taken place the only
thing we have left is purely
technological relationships this is no
longer the earth on which men
leaves hannah arendt in her human
condition of course with somewhat
changed this to argue around the first
Sputnik that man had been able to
repudiate that that's the epochal
consciousness there is a history a
narrative that the history of narrative
of globalization produced through the
Cold War years and Beyond turned around
the question of dwelling human dwelling
on earth in a process where the globe
the outcome of the history of European
expansion and the growth of capitalism
as the world system that encountered the
planet Earth simply because the earth
was there to be so encountered so it's
like so this is because this becomes the
culmination of Europe's expansion Europe
expands the world gets connected and
finally we hit the limit of the world
which is the planet so the globe the
world becomes the globe and the globe is
the planet the globe and the planet in
the end merge into one another in so far
as the globalization theorists are
concerned this was the lexical spill as
largely puts it from the word earth to
the word earth planet and gloob the
parallel turn in the environmental
movement from environment to globe as in
global environment
he points out goes in tandem with this
globalization of the world picture there
are three things to be noted about this
consciousness of globalization it turns
as I said on the question of human
dwelling humans dwelling together in a
global world when technology weaves the
planet into a huge network of
connections the history it recalls is
the history of the last 500 years or so
the history of European expansion of
globalizing capital with all its
iniquities and of modern technology and
see while the environmental concerns of
the last four decades did call attention
to man's relationship to his environment
including other species this epochal
consciousness remained profoundly home
eccentric European humans were at the
center of this narrative however it was
told so in a way I'm really trying to in
what I've trying to do so far is to open
up the history of the expression
differentiated responsibilities the
story of planetary climate change
carries with it the narrative of
globalization but also departs from it
in a radical manner the science of
climate change
has its roots going back to 19th and
20th century investigations by European
and American scientists both amateur and
professional but more immediately to the
product of the Cold War the detonation
of the nuclear bomb that made for new
oceanographic and atmospheric studies by
the United States
Spencer beard and Joshua who have
recently told this story in fascinating
detail and one of the interesting parts
the prehistory of climate science modern
climate science post-war is very much
American interest in actually using
weather as a military weapon whether you
could cause floods in the enemy's
territory or cause weather disruption in
the enemy's territory and a lot of
people were paid money to study that
mystère to see if the atmosphere could
be part made to be militarized the
science one could say as I said was
mainly American its immediate context
lay in the competition between the US
and the Soviet Union for the mastery of
space it is not even a culminating point
in the history of the ecological crisis
that for humans that Gary Marsh made and
others have acknowledged and discusses
discussed as a coming danger and the
climate crisis interestingly is not even
part of what's not even part of
environmentalism because the climate
problem could not have been actually
deciphered from within the available
narratives of environmental pollution or
with the methodological tools that allow
us to reconstruct something like the
history of capital diagnosing global
warming entailed the involvement of
other kinds of Sciences understanding
the phenomenon of climate change
required the development of a form of
planetary thinking which was as I said
both interdisciplinary as well as
interplanetary it involved a knowledge
of how Earth's systems functioned and
that itself is the development of a
sub-discipline of science which
basically developed in the 1980s but its
beginnings go back to space research of
the 1960s of geology and of the history
of life on this planet in addition to
what globalization theories take and
interesting which is the history of the
world market for production consumption
by introducing new questions of scale
environmental scale astronomical scales
for space
geological scales for time and skills of
evolutionary time for the history of
life all in search of understanding the
relationship between the history of the
planet's atmosphere its life and its
life carrying capacity and that's
promoting what can be called a life or
Zoe centric view of the history of the
planet the literature and global warming
works at a tangent to the completely
homo centric narrative of globalization
this tension is best seen in the work of
someone we will consider in the next
lecture James Lovelock of the gaia fame
in a way again I'm going back to the
expression common but differentiated
responsibilities and I'm saying
differentiated response to brings the
history of globalization to the table
but common to think common one opens up
this other history so both globalization
narratives and scientist concern over
dangerous climate change share an
interest in human well-being
but while globalization theorists argue
about the capacity of the existing
economic and political institutions to
deliver wellbeing for all humans the
science of planetary climate change ends
up making the conditions for the
flourishing of life in general on the
planet into a condition for ordinary
human flourishing the two sets of
literature that's also developed a
tension between their two master
categories humanity for globalization
and the human species for climate change
elaborating on this tension and its
implications is the task I'll set myself
in the next lecture the beginning of the
divergence between Homo centric
perceptions of the planet and what I've
called the Zoe centric view of it may be
seen in some of the key responses to the
1968 Christmas Eve American astronauts
view of Earth rise over the moon a topic
on which Robert Paul has written a very
engrossing book immediate responses to
the site of of immediate responses to
the site of both of these pictures seen
from space evoked thoughts two kinds of
thoughts that you can see the beginning
of the the the two approaches I'm
talking about the the the homo centric
and the zoe centric the immediate
responses included thoughts about human
dwelling
with astronauts spontaneously expressing
the hope that fred hoyle the astronomer
and Arthur Clarke the science fiction
writer who in turn had been influenced
by Arnold Toynbee toe and his ideas
about the unification of the world and
others that articulated in the 1950s
that humanity might now see the whole
earth as their home bringing an end to
all nationalists and other ideological
strife alongside these reactions that
focused on man there were others that
focused on life has such the
microbiologist reynad who goes extreme
art how drab and gray unappealing and
insignificant this planet would be
without the radiance of life in the
ecologist David Foster spoke of the thin
film of life that covered this planet
because this was the only colorful
object in space when you look at space
the difference between homo centric and
Zoe centric views of the world is
perhaps best illustrated to some remarks
that James Lovelock made in passing in
his book the many ages of Gaia while
recalling the time when he teamed up
with his friend Michael Alibi to write a
fictional book called the greening of
Mars trying to imagine how humans might
begin to inhabit the red planet
apparently a lobby wanted a world and
I'm quoting on which to act out a new
colonial expansion a place with new
environmental challenges and free of the
tribal problems of the earth a vision of
terraforming a word often used when
considering this act of making a planet
a place habitable or making a planet
habitable actually if you go back and
look at some of the pictures in National
Geographic of imagination of Mars as
inhabited must look like Manhattan
you're gonna wondered what it must look
like Manhattan the new settlements
terraforming to Lovelock's years had the
homo centric flavor of a planetary scale
technological fix redolent of bulldozers
and agribusiness he preferred the echo
poetic expression the making of her home
the process whose imagination does not
begin with humans but with life to make
Mars
a feat home for life right slaw block
even as he believed that Mars was too
arid to host life we shall first have to
make the planet comfortable for
bacterial life so you kind of come back
to this question of life in general
being the condition of human life
it is this latter view that places
humans firmly within a larger view of
life and planetary dynamics that I'm
calling Zoe centric for my purposes here
both these views were co-present for
instance what the American modernist
poet and the librarian of the Congress
Archibald MacLeish wrote on December 25
1968 in an immediate response to the
picture of Earth rise his poem prose
poem called Raiders riders of Earth
together brothers an eternal cold had
these two themes running through it and
I'll give you just two examples one of
what I called homo centric thinking
another one I called Zoe same trick
thinking so the homo simply just to give
you a few lines from the poem and this
is almost empty to see the earth as it
truly is small and blue and beautiful in
that eternal silence where it floats is
to see ourselves as riders on the earth
together brothers on that bright
loveliness in the eternal cold brothers
who now know that their to truly
brothers and here's the Zoe centric view
in the same poem for the first time in
all of time men have seen whole and
sound and beautiful as even Dante had
never dreamed of seeing it as the 20th
century philosophers of absurdity and
despair were incapable of guessing that
it might have it might be seen and
seeing it so one questions come to them
come to the minds of those who looked at
it is it inhabitant they said to each
other and laughed and they did not laugh
what came to their minds a hundred
thousand miles and more into space
halfway to the moon they put it what
came to their minds was life on that
little lonely floating planet the tiny
raft in the enormous empty night
is it inhabitant
in fact one of the interesting problems
that comes out of what I'm calling Zoe
centric view that geologists acknowledge
is called the habitability problem or
her planet what makes the planet
habitable again something to be taken up
so the last part of the lecture today
tonight and I want to then introduce
this distinct up in just a particular
distinction in order to think the homo
centric and the zoe centric opposition
it must be of interest to scholars in
the humanities that the word human has
turned out to be one of the most
contested and disputed categories of the
zone in the social and political
literature on climate change the use of
the word anthropos for instance in the
expression answer was any climate change
or the Anthropocene or for that matter
the use of the word human in calling
something human induced climate change
has invited the not unreasonable retort
why blame all humans are humans in
general when it is the addiction to
fossil fuel shared when the addiction is
shared only by a minority of humans the
global rich the consuming classes of the
world and of course interested groups
such as the producers and marketeers of
fossil fuels or their advocates scholars
from China India and other countries
have often complained that the word
anthropos when used thus ends up falsely
and I'm fairly implicating the poor and
their survival emissions of greenhouse
gases in the crime of those whose luxury
emissions are actually responsible for
the current crisis the word anthropos in
the expression anthropogenic climate
change has a very particular orientation
this planet Earth has seen dramatic and
planetary climate changes before what we
when we call this particular episode of
climate change anthropogenic we do so in
order to distinguish this present
episode of climate change from previous
instances of climate change that were
caused by non anthropogenic geophys
geophysical geological factors such as
shifting tectonic plates volcanic
eruptions impact of asteroids and other
things
thus we put the current episode of the
warming of the planet in a series of
similar episodes and the name
anthropogenic has the same function as
have the different sound values of
different alphabet in a caesarian
sis chain of science there is to
differentiate itself from what precedes
and what follows it the word does not
designate or Connaught an inward
oriented sense of uniqueness or
humaneness anthropos here has no moral
value and therefore it does not signify
calculate it is there simply to suggest
that the kind of geophysical force
usually needed to change the climate of
the planet as a whole
was supplied this time unlike at any
other time in the history of the planet
mainly by actions of humans it's a
causal term that does not signify any
moral responsibility but it does seem if
I causal responsibility a similar point
may be made about the use of the
anthropos in attempts by geologists to
define a new epoch called the
Anthropocene
some scholars mainly from the left have
expressed deep discomfiture and asked
why don't you call it capitalism it's
capitalism that's constant yet it's
arguable that the names of geological
periods have not normally meant to say
anything about the causes that brought
the particular period about their name
Holocene meaning recent times suggest
nothing about why an integration wom
period set in in the geological time it
designates similarly the name
Anthropocene is more about whether or
not geologists could now scientifically
argue that future geologists millions of
years from today will detect consistent
planet wise and synchronous signals in
strata of the earth suggesting that the
panic was signified ly significantly
modified by the work of a species called
Homo sapiens the name does the name does
not assign responsibility or even named
a cause but the moment we define climate
change not just as a physical phenomenon
but as dangerous the moment we say it's
dangerous climate change we are in the
realm of values and hence of
disagreement and politics you know I
have two colleagues in my geophysics
department Raymond Pierre whom Burt and
David Archer both have written books on
climate change Raymond's book which is a
text book is called planetary science
and the chapter on warming is
planetary warming this global warming is
only a part of the general category
planetary warming and here's a section
on planetary on global warming on on
this planet and it's a completely
dispassionate analysis of what goes on
he says one day it might be known as
this particular event that took away the
dinosaurs or you know some other event
David Archer writes a book which is like
an activist book and he begins by asking
people to appreciate the implications of
saying that human beings have already
changed the climate hundred thousand
years and even though he's a scientist
he begins the book by saying imagine
this what if the Greeks the ancient
Greeks had discovered for Cynthia and
lived it up three thousand years ago
would you still consider them to be the
height of Western civilization but you
can see what happens the moment you
raise questions of dangerous climate
change and dangerous can only be judged
by the use of our values we are actually
the in the realm of not causal but moral
responsibility the moment you ask
question the world's responsibility
humanity immediately fragments so an
archer is trying to persuade a group he
assumes that his readers are people who
are very invested in what you think of
the classical Greeks so actually in
effect he's actually appealing to what
he presumes to be Westerners you know
putative or real and the human problem
of climate change therefore cannot be
defined without some discussion of human
values ethics suffering in attachments
topic on which physical sciences have a
very limited purchase the idea of a
dangerous climate change is not itself a
scientific idea understanding and
defining what planetary climate change
is is indeed something for which we
depend on scientific knowledge but
dangerous is not a scientific word as my
friend and colleague Julia Thomas has
recently said historians coming to grips
with the Anthropocene cannot rely on our
scientific colleagues to define the
endangered human for us endangerment she
points out is never a simple scientific
fact it's a question of both scale and
badly
it is thus when we think of the climate
to the idea of moral and not causal
responsibilities that climate change
becomes a question of justice and hence
a political question as well who should
own the moral responsibility for the
emission of gases who should pay for it
global warming then poses a problem of
intra human justice the figure of
humanity differentiates itself from the
anthropos of the Anthropocene say at
this point we think of the political
figure of humanity as having two
somewhat contradictory characteristics
firstly it's an entity that is capable
of projecting itself into the future the
purposeful entity even though the
purpose may not always be or win
universal approval and the friend of
mine has written about interesting book
about Islamic terrorists saying that
even in the Islamic terrorists actually
are looking for a humanity if they have
a program for converting everybody into
Islam I mean this is a you know it's a
book wonderful book called terrorists in
search of a humanity as a live gene so
we have we think of humanity as this
capacity to project ourselves but we
also know that this humanity is always
already divided by issues that give rise
precisely to questions of justice one
could argue them and this is my last
paragraph what a heart to them that this
category humanity is a product of the
very process of the general Mondial
ization of the world the superimposition
of the world with the globe of the
planet
it reflects the modern formation
something brought about into being by
the techno-economic framework networks
that made this planet the home that we
saw from space let us call this figure
of one but divided humanity by the latin
word homo simply to distinguish it from
the greek anthropos that has already
been claimed by scientists even though
the words mean the same thing so when we
read the word homo used in this sense
into the word anthropos as discussed
above in the context of anthropogenic
climate change we see climate change as
a continuation of the story of
capitalist globalization accentuating
all the human iniquities that are
central to the story however told but
planetary climate change and the
Anthropocene are also events driven by
non-human nonliving vectors that work on
multiple
scales some of you to work on geological
scales while some have implications
within the time horizon of one or two
human generations that which works over
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
years cannot be brought within the realm
of policy and politics but the moment we
say we should do something to prevent
dangerous climate change we raise
questions about damages costs and
responsibilities and we read what I have
called homo back into the word anthropos
as used in the expression anthropogenic
climate change or the Anthropocene in
the politics of climate justice then one
may therefore say that homo comes to be
where anthropos was so I finished there
for this evening and the next lecture
I'll explore further the implications of
this distinction between Homo and
anthropos that I've set up and come back
to the question of people called
consciousness what it means thank you
very much